elles sont chanteuses et comédiennes les
stingers ont posé leurs valises au
théâtre de saint germain en laye le
temps d'une semaine
objectif répéter leur nouveau spectacle
anthologie ou presque un théâtre musical
dans lequel elles reprennent des
morceaux de leur répertoire
une anthologie pompeuse et déjanté
d'après les artistes pompeux ce parce
qu'évidemment une anthologie c'est les
beatles qui font une anthologie les
stingers pourrait vraiment se passer
d'une anthologie mais non elle ne se
passe jamais deux de ce genre de deux
bombes ont donc nous voilà
chantant des chansons que nous avons
chanté lors des précédents spectacles
pour pour le plaisir de revisiter ses
titres des titres qui abordent des
thèmes sérieux traité avec légèreté
parmi les chansons de leur répertoire
les sea girls au pouvoir ou encore
boudin une chanson un petit peu
grinçante sur votre vie pourrie donc on
parle vous vous avez été frappé par
votre mari vous êtes un sdf
vous vous ne mangez pas vous êtes avez
des problèmes d'anorexie mentale mais
c'est pas grave un peu du monde ça c'est
la vie du move à tout réparer comme les
sea girls the le théâtre alexandre dumas
accueille des artistes chaque semaine
l'équipe met à disposition le plateau
pour leur permettre de répéter ça permet
aussi de garder le lien avec les
artistes et d'occuper aussi toute notre
équipe au théâtre notamment l'équipe
technique qui qui est donc ravis de
pouvoir contribuer aux répétitions à la
création d'un spectacle tant au niveau
du son la lumière du plateau laisse et
girl's était en résidence au théâtre
alexandre dumas du 22 au 26 mars
le spectacle devrait être visible par le
public la saison prochaine